la vaccination qui commence donc pour
les enfants à partir d'aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs pays européens oui c'est le
cas en espagne notamment confronté à une
forte reprise de l'épidémie avec des
taux d'incidence qui explose chez les
plus jeunes les enfants de moins de 12
ans ont désormais accès à un vaccin
moins fort que celui des adultes les
précisions à barcelone de clémentine
grands les petits espagnols de 5 à 11
ans peuvent désormais eux aussi recevoir
leurs doses de vaccin contre le coc vite
19 à partir de ce mercredi alors la
raison de cette nouvelle campagne bien
ce sont les chiffres de commandes 19 qui
sont alarmants en espagne les cas
augmentent depuis mi octobre même s'ils
sont en général moins graves alors la
réponse du gouvernement espagnol c'est
d'élargir la vaccination aux enfants car
on sait que le virus circule beaucoup
plus entre les enfants contre les
adultes vaccinés je vous propose
d'écouter carla borreil épidémiologiste
et directrice de l agence de santé
publique à l'ars seul homme d'affaires
total mais ce doctorat à tania marveaux
stade durant tout le mois d'octobre nous
étions autour de 300 cadeaux madère à
barcelone et maintenant nous en sommes à
trois mille c'est dix fois plus ça a été
une augmentation progressive durant tout
le mois de novembre jusqu'à maintenant
cela continue d'augmenter nous avons un
taux de reproduction de 1,3 donc nous
nous attendons encore à une hausse des
cas au cours des prochains jours
on n'a mis qu'un jeu pour
mener à bien cette vaccination 1,3
million de doses ont été livrées à
l'espagne pour environ 3 millions
d'enfants concernés mais attention il ne
s'agit pas exactement du même vaccin que
pour le reste de la population les
enfants ne recevront que le vaccin
kaiser et il ne contiendra qu'un tiers
de la dose normale le délai a également
été allongée à huit semaines pour les
enfants contre 21 jours normalement pour
les adultes c'est donc un vaccin adapté
en conséquence qui sera injectée aux
enfants et la population espagnole il
semble assez favorable je vous propose
d'écouter les réactions des barcelonais
je pense que c'est important car les
enfants sont de grands transmetteur des
virus
pas seulement du coc vide mais de tous
les virus
je crois que c'est très important pour
tout le monde pour les enfants les
adultes c'est pareil il faut que tout le
monde soit vacciné
je suis en faveur de tous types de
vaccination il s'agit d'essayer de
frehner une maladie un virus et donc je
crois que c'est assez prouvé que le
vaccin est sûr que la dose qu'ils
injectent aux enfants c'est le tiers de
ce qu'on met aux adultes et avec un
vaccin qui est scientifiquement prouvé
et je suis complètement peur
il faut tout de même noter que cette
vaccination ne se fera pas de la même
manière dans toutes les régions
espagnoles par exemple ici en catalogne
toutes les tranches d'âge peuvent se
faire vacciner sans ordre de priorité et
cette vaccination se fera dans les
centres de santé habilité et pas dans
les écoles